au cirque on ne se lève pas très tôt les
lendemains de spectacle il est 9h ce
matin là et le cirque zavatta s'éveille
doucement un chapiteau puis autour des
autobus en guise de roulottes chaque
famille à son as sont mus approprié et
là c'est l'heure du café pour franck
zavatta s'est des muscles en achète à la
réunion et puis après on en fait comme
des camping cars on les attendait à
ménages pour notre tournée et puis voilà
donc c'est très pratique pour des
fringues et le patron du cirque zavatta
oui là vous avez un petit enfant qui
sort son lit bonjour les toitures du
cirque ouais quand le 30 au plus grand
des funambules petit funambule elle
marchera sur un film un a les joues
comme tous les matins il faut faire le
nettoyage de l'intérieur du chapiteau
ouais
nous avons une évasion
bah c'est pas très grave coucou le
babouin est une des vedettes du cirque
souvent allé en aller en liberté m
il faut juste qu'ils n'approchent pas
trop la cage des foules c'est des
prédateurs manuel et le dompteur du
cercle alors lui c'est ma niche le lion
blanc n'est pas paris
malige partage l'enclos avec deux tigres
tort imai un homme regarde le siège ils
s'approchent pas la casse pour jouer
parce que les tigres y mange on va le
manger
manuel vous vous devez quand même encore
faire attention
moi je fais très attention moi j'ai les
yeux la barre pendant que je regarde là
bas je les yeux ici je lé là bas on va
le faire monter parce que maintenant on
va laver dans son coin là allait mal et
chalets ap ap ap ap allez allez allez
allez allez allez allez ça c'est une
chose qu'ils aiment pas comme tout les
lions il n'aime pas l'eau
mallet malige style calme qui auraient
besoin d'un petit shampoing mais la
dernière fois il m'a enlevé un morceau
de doigt
ah oui il s'est retourné et il a mordu
et parmi les parties la pointe du doigt
il ya plus de noirs
allez allez allez allez allez allez
allez braves
il a déjà compris qu'est ce qu'on va
faire
ouais en diamants d'abord je préfère la
viande et voilà il a déjà compris les
trois ils ont compris déjà vous ne vous
approchez pas aux barreaux de la cage
parce qu'ils sortent les pattes pour
vous prendre et il arrive jusqu'ici
ouais
c'est à peu près 100 kg de viande par
jour mais seulement de la viande lui ah
ben oui c'est les carnivores 1 le lion
blanc il est aux tigres cette date a
sonné au cirque ils n'ont jamais vécu à
l'état sauvage
les associations de défense des animaux
elle milite pour l'interdiction des
animaux sauvages dans les cirques
elles ont d'ailleurs manifesté lors de
l'arrivée du cirque zavatta à la réunion
manuel lui affirme que ces fours sont
bien traités et même qu'ils sont heureux
de dire que je crois que c'est la
dernière chose qu'il faut attaquer parce
que syrte est libre et lenny dee
monstres et avec des études
scientifiques et les animaux dans les
cirques ne sont pas malheureux de tout
enfermé dans une cage ou dans un petit
enclos ils sont pas malheureux
absolument non à lyon dans un cirque
passe à peu vers 22 ans et c'est pas
bien deux ans de malheur ses 22 ans de
bonheur patrick et le dresseur de coco
le bavarois est parti
à la barre de qualité qui fait la pole
bonjour comment on appelle s'appelle
concours celui qu elle a dix ans et sur
les noms captivité un d'élever au
biberon ça fait dix ans que générique
moi c'est ma passion
et ceux qui disent que c'est triste
garder un animal comme ça attaché
retenue dans un cirque
c'est fait aujourd'hui ce monsieur nous
c'est notre religion peut-être mais
c'est pas pour cinq minutes en piste
on va dire que c'est de la maltraitance
et la l'autorisation de rentrer dans le
but oui oui parce que fait partie de la
famille hilary la fille de patrick elle
est acrobat com qui m'a ramené fois et
jamais d'accord dit-il fait plus
attention aux animaux que la séance ne
vient que notre chico signe le site
ah oui j'ai deux fils autre effet du
cirque aussi c'est beau c'est une
passion
dans la caravane à côté on parle italien
ronnie et son fils michael sont les
clous du site eric louis c'est la
cinquième génération de circuits
grand-père le père de les grands-pères
fait les clooney et après ces lettres
psl
si la file ronnie a bien l'intention de
poursuivre la tradition depuis qu'on ait
pété les enfants on en sait déjà
cette fois la vie du site comme les
enfants à l'école ils choisissent de
faire le pompier au le chante alors le
policier nous disent à numéros c'est ça
qui ont fait depuis des générations
ça c'est la chose plus importante pour
un clown
mais voilà on est prêts on va en scène
[Musique]